[cell phone rings]
GO, EAGLE ONE.
BOBBY? GREAT.
WHAT'S HIS LOCATION?
- HE'S HIDING OUT
IN BODEAN'S TRAILER.
GET IN THERE QUICK AND PLANT
THAT HOMING DEVICE ON HIM.
[guns click]
- WHO THE HELL ARE YOU?
OH, ARE YOU MY NEW
BOBBY DOUBLE?
- UH, YEAH.
I-I'M YOUR BOBBY DOUBLE.
- DAMN, I AIN'T THAT FAT
AND UGLY.
- YEAH. YEAH, YOU ARE, BOBBY.
- WELL, THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
HE'S A DEAD RINGER.
GET HIM DRESSED, BOYS.
- OOH!
- WOW, YOU LOOK PERFECT.
ALMOST TOO PERFECT,
WHICH RAISES A QUESTION.
HOW AM I GONNA KNOW
WHICH ONE OF US IS THE REAL ME?
- OH, I GOT AN IDEA.
WHY DON'T YOU TAKE
THIS BLINKY THING
AND PUT IT IN YOUR POCKET?
THAT WAY YOU KNOW
WHICH ONE OF US IS YOU.
- DAMN, YOU'RE SMART.
BUT WHAT IF YOU HAVE
THE BLINKY THING
AND I DON'T HAVE
THE BLINKY THING?
- THEN I GUESS THAT I'M YOU
AND YOU'RE ME.
- YOU JUST BLEW MY MIND.